so it is quickly becoming illegal to
point out that men are not women no
matter how they dress no matter what
kind of shoes they have no matter what
they paint their nails so this is an
attack not just on biology but on speech
on conscience you're not allowed to say
obvious things here's an example a
self-described feminist in Norway called
Christina Ellingson is facing a
three-year sentence in prison
she's facing the possibility of going to
jail for years because she affirmed the
reality of biological sex specifically
Ellingson tweeted that men cannot be
lesbians probably never thought about
this in any depth but it's technically
true she also said that men cannot
become mothers now again that's true but
in Norway as in all of the West the
truth is no longer a defense Norway is
now investigating her for hate speech we
of course immediately wanted to talk to
her Christina Ellingson joins us tonight
Christina thanks so much for coming on
this is one of those stories in Norway
is obviously a highly civilized country
I think it's the richest country in the
world a lot of great people in Norway
it's hard to believe this is real and so
I just want to check are we leaving
anything out
no that's right this is the case uh I've
been uh well you can't have you can't
defend women if you can't Define what a
woman is uh and all over the world
stating biological facts uh it's
considered by a lot of groups as being
directly hateful
so yeah this is uh what I've been doing
I've been stating the obvious fact that
men cannot be women men cannot be girls
yes or mothers or lesbian and now I'm
facing the risk of three years in prison
tell me how the country of Norway again
a country to which we give every benefit
of every doubt filled with good people
beautiful place but are you celebrated
as a hero by people who still believe in
science and Free Speech or people
supporting you
uh well a lot of people are supporting
me uh across the entire spectrum of
political religious everything but a lot
of people are also considering me on
level with uh someone who's calling for
genocide uh I've been compared to and
it's everything from a fascist to a
maoist to a supporter of Westboro
Baptist Church which I don't even know
what is
but basically
the entire spectrum of everything that's
bought in the world
is being held my way absolutely
but also a lot of support
are you surprised I think you're on I'm
just guessing but I think you're on the
left I don't think you're a right winger
I think you're from Norway are you
surprised by all of this
oh absolutely I'm not surprised because
uh this has been in the cards for a long
time if you can't talk about biological
reality uh it's unavoidable uh this is
simply unavoidable
um but yeah no I I
align myself with that with radical
feminism
um I've been uh voting left all my life
uh now I'm much more critical to
what they are actually saying and it
seems like but it seems like all parties
in Norway
um are supporting this pseudoscience
scary we know the feeling thank you for
joining us tonight Christine Ellington
very much appreciate it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight